Um, do you want to
I know a couple folks have not takers in
here. Do you want to make me host and I
can I can We're going to drop the
notetakers because we'll be pushing this
to YouTube.
Yes, I generally do that. But yes, we
should do that.
I hate the summaries that they put in
the chat sometimes.
Um
Oh, yeah.
I think today's episode is going to be
really really fun. Uh we'll start at
10:05 as per usual. But while we're um
while we're catching up on this, a few
of you probably got our email from last
time uh that was coming through it. What
did everyone think? Uh did it feel good?
Did it feel too AI generated? Give us
feedback so we can make it better.
You can type in the chat or just hop off
mute and just ask.
You're outsourcing your 5e valves. I
see.
I am outsourcing my 5e valves.
Yeah. I mean, my feedback, I guess, is
that it was very human. I'm currently
disappointed to hear that it was not
human written.
[Laughter]
He got you. Vibbov got you.
Yeah.
That's a hard problem I think facing our
industry which is
it does not feel good to be you know
reading AI content.
Well, one of the things that we do is I
I agree but one of the things like we do
is we do this content live. So for
people that want the human content, they
can come out here, but it does take like
10 or so hours to do a lot of the
follow-up work that comes from the
content afterwards
like send you everything
and like just No, I'm not saying I don't
understand like just the pure
human hours saved. Yeah.
Right. That's why it's a problem. If if
it was just like why are you doing this?
Stop. Then it wouldn't be a problem, you
know?
Yeah. I also like I've definitely I I
definitely feel the like exhaustion from
AI content. I was having like a
conversation with a guy on X last week
and every question I had, he would
respond to me with like a link to like a
notion page that was clearly just like
entirely written by 03 and it was like
10 pages of slop and I was just like,
"All right, man. If you're not even
going to try, then I'm out of here."
Yeah.
I think the I think the slop is what
really bothers me. I we actually have a
thing in our team where like
we don't want to discourage people from
using AI for writing docs
but one of the things that we do is we
put a little snippet in the notion that
says this was written by Chad GBT and
then it's like a collapsible section
that people can read. So it's very
upfront, very and like no one has to
guess whether you chat GPT your notes or
not because that's the worst when it
feels like you ask them to write a doc
and like [__] did you just chat GBT this
whole thing and like not even read it
where but if they
you start with this was AI generated
content and you let someone know that I
think it's a lot better of a dynamic and
a relationship between both people
because both people can opt
well and you did that in the email right
the email says at the end I mean we were
talking about doing an episode on like
tactics for authenticity but here's
Here's your here's your mini episode
which is uh yeah if you declare that
something is AI generated it becomes a
lot easier to um
I think if I can find it
get away with uh I'm not saying get away
with it but it's just like it it becomes
a lot more authentic of like hey I made
this with AI like let me know if it
sucks like I actually put in time and we
reviewed it but it was it was originally
AI generated I think you polish these a
little bit before you paste them in
right
um no this one was actually directly
past
this one was just raw Huh?
Oh, I did do some I did do some editing.
Um, let's see if I can find the unicorn
emoji.
I I actually just went through in zero
inbox this morning. Um,
I can I can find the email from you.
Uh, I can pull up on just to give people
context like this is a problem that I
think is really really hard to go solve.
So, we spent about two episodes talking
about this in the last two episodes
which was specifically how can you go
send
a content that doesn't feel as bad.
Let's see if I can see the preview. So,
this is what the email was listed as
like hello coder. We linked to the
actual repo. We didn't get the exact
full path in the repo. That's something
we want to improve. We got the YouTube
link in there. We got a little summary
with things uh in there. The bolding
didn't work. I did have to do that
manually. I It gave me double asterisk,
but
mark down.
Uh we have the next session link that
was AI generated uh thanks to the work
that Dexter did that we talked about.
And then this thing was uh manually
added by me and that was done for that
reason which was just to let people know
that's an AI generated email using our
content pipeline that we built over the
last two episodes and just shared that
with folks.
So if you if you haven't gotten this
email, sign up. You'll get an email this
week from this week's recording. Um, but
with that, uh, let's get back into
today's
Let's talk memory.
Let's talk context engineering. But
yeah, it's gonna be really fun. Um, so
for those of you that don't know, I'm
VIBO. I'm one of the co-creators of
BAML. And this is
Dexter. Who is
I'm Dexter. I am uh I work on uh a
company called Human Layer. um build
tools to help people build better AI
agents and agents that feel more like
real people. And we have a very special
guest with us today. Um we got Brian
who's another very awesome YC founder
who is actually building products that
all the things we've been talking about
for the last two months. Brian is
building these into a real product that
real people use and get value out of. So
I Brian, you want to uh any further
further intro or you want to talk about
kind of what you've been working on
briefly?
Sure. I mean, we're gonna go more into
depth later on, but um I'm Brian. Um no,
Dexter, no viab. Um but yeah, we're I
work at a company called Orin. Um we're
basically building all of these like AI
principles into like proactive um first
AI tutors for mostly middle schoolers
these days. So, it's a very very
hands-on application of all of these
things into education space. So, excited
to jump into it.
Cool. Cool. Thanks, Brian.
With that, let's let's talk about the
thing that we're going to talk about
today, which is context engineering. The
word has been going around a lot.
Dexter, you gave a great talk about it
at the AI engineer summit, but what the
heck is context engineering? What are
all these terms that people toss around?
Is it a real thing? Is it more just like
vibes? I Let's talk about it in detail
today. And I think the thing I want to
start with is actually the diagram that
Dexter has made because I think it
really solidifies what this is.
Yeah. You want to pull it up?
Pull it up. Go ahead and screen share.
I'll let you drive.
Um, so this is a chapter from
one second.
Yeah, go ahead.
Uh, and just so everyone knows, the
benefit of the Zoom call is you're
welcome to chime in, ask questions as
you go on. Otherwise, you can always
watch the recording on Fridays as it
goes live.
Um, but if you have questions, just hop
off uh hop off mute or if it gets to be
too wieldy, uh, just like raise your
hand and then or type in the chat. We'll
keep an eye on it.
Yeah, this is not meant to be totally
this is not meant to be totally one way.
uh drop in your questions, come off
mute, ask tell us tell us what you think
is wrong, tell us what you've seen in
the real world. Um we're all figuring
this out together. Uh which is uh leads
us into speaking of figuring this out
together. So this is a chapter from
12actor agents um which was published in
April and one of the diagrams I think I
think I remember actually when I vibar
reviewed an early version of this in
like late March and he saw this diagram
said this is the best diagram in the
entire paper. Um and it's basically this
idea that like LMS are completely
stateless functions. Um, and the only
thing that affects the quality of your
AI application is the quality of the
tokens that are coming out of your
model. And the only thing that affects
the quality of the tokens that are
coming out other than like tuning things
like temperature and uh training your
own model is the tokens you put in. And
so while people will say that rag and
memory and agentic history and prompt
engineering are all kind of like
different like disciplines and you need
different tools and they're all like
have their own like blackboxy
implementations. Um at the end of the
day it's all just strings going into
models and tokens in and tokens out. Um,
there's a little bit of the structured
output thing, which I think uh is uh
probably part of why Vibb really likes
this because structured outputs is not
just what the model outputs, but what
you do with it and how you parse it and
how you turn it into data for a program
to use. Um, but this really popped off.
I think it was like June 12th that uh
the cognition guy did a blog post. I'm
actually going to put a I'm going to
post something soon of like the history
of the term context engineering and
where it came from and all the different
people who kind of like I think kind of
came to the same conclusion around the
same time. Um but there was a tweet from
Toby Lutkkey in June um talking about he
loves context engineering. Andre
Karpathy jumped on the train. There's
now a hundred blog posts about context
engineering that you can go read about.
Um but today we're going to go deep into
code and we're going to talk about the
anatomy of a prompt and the anatomy of a
context and how you can build this stuff
programmatically.
Yeah. And I think um do you want to pull
up the whiteboard really fast?
Yeah, let's do it.
And just to give everyone a summary of
all the concepts that we'll be covering
today uh just as a brief high level
overview. The agenda for today is we're
going to go share um how to build each
of these contexts into the prompt. We'll
do a very high level overview of exactly
how rag is context, how prompt and
during is context, how state and history
are context, and how memory is context.
So we'll actually build out some of
these prompts, write them by hand, talk
about some of the analogies in there. Um
after that we're gonna deep dive into
memory and focus a little bit more on
memory because we've got this awesome
guest Brian um on the show and he is
going to he's generous enough to talk
about some his blog post that both Dex
and I were super impressed by uh that
really outlines some details around
memory that I think a lot of people
overlook. Um, and but I think that level
of context engineering of how you go do
that is the key to making applications
feel like magic when using LMS. It's
like the same thing like when you when
you first use an app and like you use a
gesture on it, it just feels right.
Like for those of you that don't like
reverse scrolling on your Mac, you're
wrong. But for the rest of us, it feels
natural when you scrolling.
And that's the whole point of it. um it
just feels right when you try a UX
pattern for the first time. And the same
way when you use an L1 and to do that to
make it feel right, you got to context
engineer, right? So with that, let's
write some prompts and look at how all
this fits into the actual context
engineering piece.
So in the whiteboard, we've got a few
things.
Yeah.
The first one is then that like what is
your prompt going to end up looking
like? So I think the first thing that
people write is a prompt that has a
bunch of like a you are kind of role
with a system instruction or something
up here. Um I have opinions about that.
I will refrain from sharing that right
now. Um because I think that's
irrelevant to the point that we're
trying to make here. uh which is
well it's just like prompt engineering
is one one element of your context that
you pass in whether it's the system
prompt or the user message and I think
it's kind of like we're going to stay a
little more high level than like advice
on any particular one and we're going to
drill down memory because I think it's
the most underserved the most hotly
debated and the most like valuable thing
to get right
exactly so this UR concept is uh is like
a prompted juring trick that we're So,
every single thing you've heard from
like I'll tip you $10 to do things or
you must be correct or do not
hallucinate. All of those are prompt
engineering tips. And whether you choose
to put this message in a pro in a system
message or whether you choose to put it
in a user message
um is really also prompt engineering.
The fact that Enthropic only allows you
to send a system message if you send at
least one user message. That's a prompt
engineering constraint that they've
applied on their system. The fact that
images can't be passed into user
messages or can't be passed into system
messages for a lot of things. That's
again another constraint applied by the
model that you have to go do. So
whenever people do prompt engineering, I
think they stop at just the words that
they're using. But I think one important
thing to think about when you do prompt
engineering when you think about the
context building around it is the kind
of model that you're using and what
affinities it has and what you should be
doing. So for example, OpenAI is clearly
doing some work to capture prompt
injections and stuff that disobey the
system message and try and train the
model for that benefit. So you might
benefit towards trusting OpenAI more and
more and using system messages for them.
On the other hand, Enthropic seems to
have guidance that you should just use
the user message whenever possible
instead of a system message. So you
should just do that because the model
people are they're biasing the way that
they train the model to go do that. And
part of context engineering isn't just
assembling this. It's actually being
aware of what affinities each model has
and actually learning that along the
way. And that that's just vocab that we
have to learn. It's kind of like when we
use databases, we decide that Reddus is
really good for a quick in-memory
system, but you would never put your
entire database purely on Reddus if you
need cold storage that can never die.
It's just the wrong database to use for
that tool. And most people don't have to
know that, but your database engineer at
your company better know that. Similarly
true for models. At some point, the best
context engineers are going to know the
nuances about the models, and that's
just part of the job. Anything you want
to add on to that, Dex?
Um, no. I think that makes a ton of
sense. Sorry, I'm just going to pause
for a sec while I go close a bunch of
tabs.
Okay. Yeah, go for it.
Cool. With that, let's talk about the
next thing. Rag.
Cool.
I think the way that most people do rag
is also very um very interesting because
rag is I think rag actually in my
opinion rag lives in a hybrid both in
and outside of the model. Uh it's a
little bit it it kind of behaves like
structured outputs in that sense. Um and
I think the reason for that actually
with that let's talk about structured
outputs first then go into rag. Um, I
wanted to go in the circle, but I think
because rag behaves slightly
differently, I want to talk about
structured outputs. It's like why is
structured outputs in and out of the
model? Well, we've probably all seen
these things about like where you can
use like a whole bunch of different
tools. You can use XML, you can use like
we can use BAML's format, we can use
like JSON, we can use like uh we can
have it emit Python code that we then
run into a Python data model directly.
There's so many different ways of doing
structured outputs and All of these
methods involve two parts. They involve
a method that involves both. Actually, I
have a great diagram for this.
Drop it in.
Let me Yeah, that's what I'm meant to
do.
Are you able to just paste the image
into the whiteboard?
I can I can
cool.
Um,
I think when it comes to structured
outputs, there's like these three
diagrams that a lot of people
um Let's see. Oh, I cannot I I can
screenshot and then paste the image in.
When it comes to structured outputs,
there's like three parts that we
basically have in the model. We have the
prompt that we actually have. We have
the actual model itself and then we have
the code that we run outside of it. The
context
so JSON schema.
So JSON schema and this is part of it is
like when you when you use the OpenAI
SDK and you put tools in like if you
read their docs essentially or any any
of these model SDKs, right? When you
when you pass tools into a method or
push them into an API endpoint, you're
passing JSON schemas that then get
encoded and injected into the system
message in a way that like the model has
been trained on basically.
Yeah. And I'm going to I'm going to put
like a couple different tools in here
just so we have the screenshots
um as I go talk really fast. and go
capture these.
Yeah. No, these are great.
Um, and just so people know how context
engineering works with structured
outputs because it is very nuanced and
it's not to say that there's one right
answer. I think that's the whole point
of these conversations. There is no
right answer. Um, all of it is really
really based around
uh just understanding the tools that you
have at your leisure to then go ahead
and go make these things actually better
along the way. Okay. So I think I have
all the
this one is constrain generation, right?
Uh
yes, exactly.
Yeah. Where it's like the output is
actually like the sampler gets struck
out for anything that's not valid JSON.
Exactly. So like how is structured
output context engineering? Well, the
point is I think in the very beginning
at the thing at the very top if you want
to scroll up.
Yeah.
Yeah. There you go. This is the most
trivial way to do structure generation.
You write the prompt, the model does its
thing and you run JSON.parse.
There's different tuning things that we
can do. So for example, we can do
context engineering by using some prompt
engineering to say your output should do
exactly that. The model does whatever.
Then we run JSON.parse.
We can do better.
Jason, you got a question.
Yeah, I didn't want to interrupt by Bob
there, but
go for it. Would you consider like MCP a
structured output like uh the the schema
that goes along with an MCP server and
then the tools that go with it? Would
you consider that like a structured
output of sorts for the for the model
that then gives back a different output
of its own?
Um I think MCP falls into it's like a
higher level concept than just like
purely context engineering. And if
you're using an MCP server as an input
into a prompt, then yes, you're
basically doing structured outputs with
an MCP server.
That's all you're doing.
Go ahead.
Yeah, the canonical way to use MCP is to
use the list tools endpoint, get back
the JSON schema in a format that then
you can just send to the uh model
endpoint in the same way that like any
normal nonMCP client would request a
tool call and tell it about the schemas.
For what it's worth, it might work. It
might work a little differently with
anthropics models because it's like the
protocol's opinionated about anthropics
models, but that's how everything else
implements it like Gemini or whatever
and cursor is it's yeah it's just
calling list tools and then passing them
in as like normal nonMCP tools like the
model doesn't know that it's that it's
MCP only anthropics like models are
aware of MCP as a thing which exists
separately from normal tools and prompt
context. Oh, they're actually aware of
that in the prompt API.
Yeah. So, this is like why um anthropics
models support other primitives like
resources for example. um is
because and like why cursor and one surf
don't support resources is because it's
a separate MCP like
primitive or API or whatever you want to
call it that
yeah it's different from tools but it's
difficult to model as tools and so most
and so it's not portable to other models
because they don't have a predefined way
to understand it in their system prompt
and so you would kind of have to educate
the model about what they are and what
they do or kind of like wrap them as
tools and So it's not portable. So
people just generally use tools.
Okay, cool. Thanks, Kyle.
Cool.
Um, all right. So go to go back into
that. The next thing that we could do is
we could do better prompt engineering
where we say say I don't know if it
doesn't know the answer and then we'll
literally say if I don't know is in the
output, return something else otherwise
JSON.parse. And you can clearly see how
we're doing context engineering on the
left side and doing something else on
the right side. And that's the point of
this. This is not all context
engineering.
The other thing you can do is you can do
constraints.
So you're saying this stuff on the left
is like the tokens you send into the
model is context engineering but there's
a little bit part of this where like
your parsing afterwards needs to kind of
know about what you put into the context
and so it's kind of bridges those two
sides.
Exactly. You're kind of touching both
ends. The next part of the approach is
something like this where you actually
modify the model. you send you you do
send some tokens in like the JSON scheme
or something else and then the model
basically limits you to only follow JSON
grammar specifically.
So we're not we are doing context
engineering in the fact that we're
giving it JSON schema or some spec. But
then instead of our parser having
knowledge the model has knowledge of
what to go do and this has trade-offs
that we've talked about many times.
Basically constraint generation probably
hurts that output quality but it is a
technique that you can leverage.
The next thing that
yeah we'll link to the other episode
where we talked about that a little bit
more in depth especially for codegen.
Yeah the other episode the other thing
you can do over here is you can use tool
calling. Tool calling is very similar.
You do you do a special kind of context
engineering where you send in the tools
in a special field into your API call as
special tokens into the model. And now
the model limits what tools you return
using the JSON struct using the JSON
approach that they have over there as
well. the same approach as this
constraint generation and then you also
have to change your parser to read
output.tools instead of just the raw
string from now on. So now we have we've
modified both the context and the model
and also the parser.
And then you have the last technique
which is one that we do which is you do
context engineering to inject the data
type into the prompt but you don't
change the model and you basically just
run a special parser that is able to go
ahead and take again take knowledge of
what you put into the prompt and parse
it out. XML is the same way. You have to
know that you gave the prompt XML format
to then run XML.parse instead. It
doesn't just magically work. And that's
exactly why the thing at the top that
Dexter is showing you, you go to the
top. That's why structured outputs lives
on this bridge. Your context has to know
about structured outputs, but so do many
other things, including possibly the
model and the supporting code around it.
Um, I saw that there's a question in the
middle. Sorry to have uh gone on for a
bit. Do you want to hop on and ask your
question?
Yeah, come on. Yes. So I I was just
thinking of context as different
sections or different types. One could
be knowledge again or you have memory
and etc. that ven diagram actually
explains it better. So when you talk
about context I think giving some nuance
or basically where we uh give tags or
different identifiers for the context is
helping it break down. So that also sort
of helps us map out what the context is.
Right? For example, you might give
knowledge, you might give instructions.
Uh for example, even a structure for its
output or input is also again an
instruction for the LLM to follow. Do
you agree?
Kind of. I think the fact that you're
labeling a section as some section is
just a prompt engineering technique. So
like if you're labeling this as like if
you add an instruction here that says
like structure uh is like schema and you
like let's say you did some tags like
this
where you you put some tags like this in
your prompt.
That's a prompt engineering trick you're
employing to go do this. The thing that
is context is the full prompt that you
send in. The full prompt as is the
actual API request you make fully is
your context.
The sections of it are an abstract
concept that we are making up right now.
But really the only context that matters
is the tokens in and the tokens out
even.
And you could put this stuff in any
order. You could put your structured
output instructions in the system
message or the user message. They're
kind of orthogonal concepts.
You could put it at the beginning, you
could put at the end. Like all of these
are totally different. You could scatter
it four times in your prompt, repeating
it different times. You could put it
without these tags, without these tags.
or or with these tags it doesn't really
matter but you have to try different
things to get the right model to
understand.
Does that answer your question BJ?
It does. Thank you.
And so we split this up into
Yeah, sorry. Go ahead.
I was going to say we split this up into
kind of parsing and instructions
basically. That's how kind of would
clarify this. And it's kind of like when
you're writing an essay, like there's a
general guiding for writing a good
essay. You have an introduction
paragraph, you have three body
paragraphs, and you have a conclusion
paragraph. That's a pretty good
structure in general, but not all essays
have to follow that format. It's the
same with prompts. There's probably good
guidelines for prompts, and you should
probably follow them, especially if the
model providers are giving you some
suggestions.
But they're not the end all beall. And
you have to remember that everyone is
discovering the capabilities of these
models at roughly the same time. Even
the model providers are also discovering
them at roughly the same time. Like all
this emergent behavior is new to them as
well. So whenever a company whenever
someone comes out and says this is the
best prompting technique and they happen
to work at openthropic,
they just discovered that for the first
time. No one has all the context right
now because the space is moving so fast.
So just remember
like no one designed the models to be
good at XML or be good at parsing XML.
people just over time we're trying lots
of things and realize oh if you put XML
into the model it's really good at
focusing the types of attention on the
certain stanzas that you want
and the reason by the way that people
seem to perceive XML is better I don't
actually think it is is because the
parsing of XML is much more tolerant to
escape tokens than the parsing of JSON
so YAML is whitespace specific JSON
doesn't even allow most types of whites
space XML is a lot more forgiving and so
like if you have the model writing code
and the code has new lines, it's very
hard for the it's much harder for the
model to write slashn instead of an
actual new line character because most
of the code in the training set is
written with real new lines, not with
the slash and the n.
Exactly. So when that happens, what ends
up happening is you're just biasing
towards certain directions. Anyway, we
got we're Yeah, we're almost 20 minutes
in. We got to we got to hit the other
categories quickly.
Yes. What's up, John?
Sorry, I couldn't figure out the how to
raise a hand, so I'm just dropping in.
Um, so I love this diagram, but one of
the thing I'm kind of struggling with is
that the right now it's kind of like a
mixing up both um behavioral instruction
like a how to with the factual
information like either rag or memory
we're going to talk about. Is it is it
helpful to like even split out that
Yeah. Yeah. there like a instructional
versus factual like a context.
Depends on the model. It honestly
depends on the model. Some models
benefit from having it in different
places. Um
I will we'll show some prompts in a
second that show how to go write this,
but it really really really varies. Um I
wish I think about machine learning that
a lot of people I think have a hard
thing is like we all in software
engineering we have llinters that make
us say like this is the right way to
name our variables. this is the right
way to structure our code and there's
often a right answer for so many things.
But
this whole context engineering piece is
much more like a system design interview
question where it's all about trade-offs
in different dimensions and just
understanding the trade-offs
and that's how you
and like observability as well. I'll use
that more generally obviously in in LM
world it's more like eval but like the
idea of like how will you know when you
try I I work with a lot of teams and
they end up like just trying every
technique and every paper without
knowing how they will know what's better
and what's not and like I don't know
what's better and every problem domain
and every model is different and so when
you think of this as all kind of like
overlapping parts of this challenge of
how do I get the right tokens into the
LLM so I get the best quality answer
it's it's a mindset shift and This
encourages you to kind of like open your
awareness and your your approaches. I
don't know what's best, but I know the
more things you can try and the more
flexible you are with how you mix this
and interle this information together,
the more likely you are to stumble on to
and discover some emergent property of
like, oh, when we do it this way, it's
actually like 20% better. And that makes
our agent go from like kind of just a
toy to like, oh, this actually solves
real problems reliably.
Exactly.
Yeah. That's kind of like John's comment
right now is that how to measure best is
like is it more factual? Is there more
like a usable for next like software to
use. So anyway,
let's keep going. I'll probably follow
up with you guys.
Yeah, we did a chat on eval like a
couple episodes back. If you go on the
YouTube channel, you'll find it. Um
let's talk about rag and I'll talk about
why rag is very similar to structured
outputs in this sense and why we should
update this diagram accordingly. Um,
well, the way rag works is also very
similar. You have a bunch of context
that lives in some database somewhere,
and we're going to want to pull parts of
this. Oops, sorry. Pulled the wrong
diagram. I'm not as fast at Excel Draw
as Dexter is. Um, he's a beast at this
stuff. Uh, we have a bunch of
I just love I played too many RTS games.
I I'm obsessed with hotkeys.
I can tell. Um, and what we will want to
do is we'll want to pull some of these
contexts and put them into our prompt.
That is naive rag. That is the most
naive form of rag that you can do. It's
just like in structured outputs. If you
scroll down, Dexter,
the most naive form of structured
outputs that we can do is literally dump
the uh is literally dump the JSON schema
into the problem and just JSON pars.
You're right.
And hope it didn't put markdown back
ticks around the JSON. Hope. Pray.
Right. Exactly.
That it didn't.
Yeah.
So, but on the other hand, what we
really want to do with rag is rag is a
problem. And the way that I think about
the problem is it's basically a problem
that looks at this function signature.
It takes in some query of some type T
and returns a ve of another of a data
type. That's all a rag function is.
Whether I use a vector database or
anything else for that doesn't really
matter. It's really up to me as an
engineer to decide
retrieve retrieval. This is just the
retrieval part, right? Like I would say
like
this is the R, this is the a
augmentation augmenting your context
with more info and then the generation
happens when you send it all to the
model.
Exactly. And a lot of people think rag
is about the model. Rag is not about the
model. Rag is purely about retrieving
the right data and then the way you
augment it into the prompt is the way
that you're rendering into the prompt.
So you could dump it in directly. You
could dump it in reformatting it in a
way that's different for the model. So
we talked about like rendering XML
schemas instead of JSON schema or
rendering BAML schema instead of JSON
schema or wrapping with these schema
tags around your schema part of it. It's
the same thing. The way you render is up
to you. There's a thousand ways to
render the same context in your prompt
and you have to decide which way that
is. And that's why rag sits on the
border of context interning because you
have to choose how you augment the model
and you have to choose how you get the
context. And the parameters that you
choose to get the context may not even
be ones that are fed directly into the
model. It may be a totally different
query than the direct user message
you're putting in. It's just a function
that takes in a query, spits out some
data, and then you have a function that
has a
I should write this this way. Dev render
to prompt.
Yep.
That takes in a data object of type data
and spits out really this should speak
spit out
a ve of tokens, but I will just say it's
a string.
I'll say it's a ve of tokens. And the
reason I'll say that specifically is
because one rag context doesn't have to
be a string. It can easily meet it can
easily just be like for example each rag
context could be its own user message.
It could be a user and system message
pair. It could be a system message. It
could be a user assistant message. If a
new model comes out with a new message
type, it could be that.
And that's why there's overlap here.
That's why the prompt engineering is
overlapped with rag because how you use
these system and user tokens might be
interled with how you pass context to
the model. And I've seen a lot of things
where it's like you go retrieve all the
documents, but actually the thing that
works best is user asks a question and
then the system returns I need this and
then you put it in as a new user message
for the answer. And that's a better way
to get the model to pay attention to the
data in the rag chunks.
Exactly. Um, and as you can probably
guess, state and memory are the exact
same thing. People call it rag, people
call it state, people call it history,
people call it memory. All of them are
basically the same thing. You're using
context to pull some data in and then
you're rendering it into the model. The
rendering part is the context
engineering. The pulling part is some
excess code that you will write that
looks like this. And that is
I think the naive
sorry I was going to say like the
the naive uh the naive rag is basically
uh just embed the query and send it in.
We did a long thing about embeddings and
rags and stuff like that. Memory can
just be thought of as like rag against
past conversations. And again, that's
the naive thing. But it doesn't have to
just be an embedding comparison in a
cosign distance, right? This function,
this query of t, this t object could be
a string that the user asked. It could
be a string that the user asked plus the
user's ID plus like the date of the
query and a time range to query memory
for because all of that could be stuff
in your UI where they say I only want to
consider memory. So like memory becomes
this more complex thing where like when
you get your memory context, your object
that you use to fetch it could be a
combination of like okay we're going to
filter only things from a certain time
range. We're going to summarize them
before but at the end of the day we're
going to come back with data that's
going to get pushed into the prompt.
Yeah. And I think like conversationally
the way that we use rag is rag is
usually a backed against factual data
and that's what people nomenclaturely
call rag. Memory is usually the same
kind of conversation but against
previous uh like information about the
about the person that's interacting with
the system or the entity that's
interacting with the system. And then
state and history usually refers to like
conversations more focused on the actual
uh stuff that's going on currently in
the or more focused on the context that
like the past interactions that that
system has had. memory.
It's like your actual like chat history
basically.
Yeah. And it's very different than
memory because memory to me is more like
factualized information that are already
aggated in some summarized. So for
example, if I go to chat GBT
let's just see what it says. Um uh am I
screen sharing? I don't know if you want
to screen share.
You are not. You want to screen share?
Uh did you put a link in?
Um I'm screen sharing.
No, I I I don't know if you want to
share. Yeah, I am now.
Stop share.
I did. Yeah, go for it. Uh, it is
sharing. Yeah, if you go to the top
tabs, if you don't see Vibe off screen,
you can go to the Zoom top tab and
select it.
Okay. So, like for example, it's like,
well, I like what are five words that
describe me.
If I put this on here,
this is going to be a memory task. And
this is slightly different. Uh, nice.
I'm playful. Uh, this is slightly
different. uh than than a lot of other
uh uh things as opposed to state in
history. Stay in history is me asking it
about the same conversation two or three
times. That's stay in history. But
memory is more just like using
factualized information having being
able to have a conversation about this.
Um
yeah, Brian, that's why I did that and I
didn't ask Desk to do it because I
wasn't sure. I didn't want to make him
say no in case he didn't want to do it.
I was like whatever. We'll see what it
says. Impatient and irritable would
probably be mine. I like I like to yell
at GPT in all caps. It seems to work
well.
Um,
cool. Um, that's the whole point of
engineering.
Does this make sense to you in terms of
like assistant and user as part of state
and history? Like this is like your chat
history and how you tell the model. And
like again, you could use assistant and
user messages or you could just put,
hey, here's the past conversation and
stuff it all into one user message. And
this is the context engineering part.
Yes. So, what I want to do for the next
uh 10 minutes uh really fast is I want
to do some live prompting, but before we
do that, I want to check really fast
with Brian and see if we want to get him
on first to talk about some of the stuff
that he's been doing in memory and talk
about his blog post. And then after
that, we'll do some of the actual
prompting in the second part of the
show, which goes over. So, you can watch
the recording if you'd like or stay on
where we do live coding. But I think
what we should be doing right now is I'd
love to have Brian come on and actually
Deck, do you want to pull up his blog
post while he does it?
Yeah. So, Bri Brian sent me this a while
ago. I thought this was one of the best
uh like practical guides on how to build
agents. It goes through all this
proactive stuff and when to trigger
things and there's a really nice like
concise zero slop section on like how
they do short-term versus long-term
memory and stuff like this. So, I saw
this and I was like, we're going to do a
memory episode. I would love to have
Brian come in and talk about kind of how
he thinks about this and sort of the
lessons they learned along the way and
maybe maybe if we can convince him if
he's feeling generous to uh share some
code.
Do you want to blog post
and Brian can walk us through?
Yeah, I can I I can share screen with
the blog post and should be able to go
show some some code and some logs and
stuff just for local data.
Can you guys see the blog post on my
screen?
Yes.
Are we good? Wonderful. Um,
I think like all the stuff you're saying
about memory is correct where it's like
it's really just a form of context
engineering, but how you do it I think
is very use case specific. Um, like for
example for for us for tutoring, it's
okay like we want to have this agent
kind of exist and and kind of be a
partner to families throughout months
and hopefully years as well. And so it's
okay if like it can't remember the exact
thing that happened like 14 months ago,
right? Like if it can just get the
general like what were we doing roughly
in that season, you know, that's fine,
right? Um and but we need to be very
like very episodic where it understands
like how has the students progressed
through time, right? Um we care less
about like, you know, your dog's name is
Charlie versus uh what were you like bad
at a month ago, right? We want to know
more of the episodic stuff than the
factual things.
And so we basically had to had to figure
out a way to like
how did we Yeah. Go ahead.
To interrupt you. It sounds like the
first thing that you guys did is you
defined really clearly what was the
success criteria for your thing. Like it
sounds like very clearly, you know, you
don't care about knowing your dog's
name. You do care about knowing like
educational progress of the student over
time. And I know that seems obvious
obviously like hearing that that seems
super obvious to me about your problem
statement. and it's like, "Oh, you're
brilliant tutoring app. Obviously, you
don't care about your dog's name." Um,
but I can also see how someone did an
email or like showed their boss that
didn't do that. Someone could be upset
by it, but like you've clearly made a
very hard stance. So, like this is like
it seems like you communicate across
your team even what is a success
criteria with a pretty good like herring
test that someone else can run and be
like, "Oh, does should this pass? Should
this not pass?" Which I kind of really
like about what you just said there.
Yeah. It's less about like the dog's
name or like that specific fact, but
more like what type of information do we
care about having in the long run,
right? So, uh, a lot of times like the
core insight here is that when people
are buying or paying for tutoring, um,
they need to feel like they're able to
offload the cognitive workload of of
managing somebody's learning, right?
Like that's kind of the value that
you're you're you're actually
purchasing. And so if if you can't trust
that the solution that you're purchasing
is um like able to keep track of what
your kid is doing in the long term and
like how they're progressing and all
that stuff and like maybe like
remembers, oh you're on vacation this
week and so let's not do lessons, but
also like you know last year we had
trouble in math like let's let's hammer
in the algebra this year, right? Like
stuff like that is kind of what you're
paying for. And so if we'd obviously
love to know what your dog's name is and
and remember that, but like if we had to
pick one, we have to optimize for one
first.
Um,
and I'm not having the chat up, so if
there's questions in there, let me know.
Yeah, show off the diagrams that you I
think those are sick.
Well, I like also this like conversation
about like how you decided to like
basically like what made you decide to
want to build this yourself versus like
outsource it to one of the frameworks
out there that are all quite popular and
in broad use.
Yeah. Like honestly like after doing a
deep dive and this was a few months ago
stuff has changed like I didn't really
see products that were super focused on
this like episodic temporal memory. It
was a lot of stuff that was focused on
like these knowledge graphs, which is
great for for use cases that are like
much more workflow driven where it's
like I want the agent to do a certain
thing but also know a bunch of stuff
about doing the thing. Um, but like that
just wasn't as important to us.
Um, and so we basically decided like,
hey, let's just build our own temporal
agent memory because like the naive
solution to this, which we thought was
kind of naive, but um, turns out like
required a lot of nuance, ended up being
really good. Um, and so because we
didn't care as much about like knowing
what was happening exactly, you know, a
year ago and like this the exact
specifics of that, we ended up building
what we call decaying resolution memory.
Um, which is like kind of exactly what
it sounds like. We basically take all of
the ground truth of what has happened
and it's this diagram is actually a
little bit out of date right now. Um, we
don't take the actual messages, we do
summaries of the direct interactions. So
like after one um one like run of the
agent
it's uh
someone question
uh Jerry mute that person.
How you doing?
I think he's on the phone or something.
All right, Jerry is now muted. Jerry,
come off mute if you have a question.
Cool.
um we we take all of the the direct
summaries of um kind of what we call
like interactions, but there doesn't
actually have to be a human on the other
side of the interactions. Like our agent
can wake up and not be talking to you.
It can just be doing stuff behind the
scenes. Um we take a summary of all of
those things and that's like our ground
truth of what happened, but like the
agent might be waking up 10 or 20 times
every day depending on like the
relationship. And so that's like way too
much to just throw into a, you know, the
front of your prompt and do context
engineering that way. And so we have
this like memory system that as memories
get older, it clumps them into like
lower resolution summarized chunks,
right? And so we're like a year ago, um,
you'll have monthly chunks of like,
okay, last June we were doing this,
right? and kind of this is all the
notable stuff about last June which
isn't going to be that big right it's
like we're going to it's very lossy but
our hypothesis is that like most of the
stuff from last June is like not that
important to remember you know but then
as you get closer to now like for this
week you have much more specific
granular data about like I think right
now we do um I can look at this in a
minute but I think right now we do um
like every for the for today we store
the direct interactions and that gets
fed into the model. But then for uh
like the last week's worth of days um we
have daily summaries and then for like
the last n weeks we have weekly
summaries and the last forever we have
monthly summaries for the rest of it.
And so what that becomes is like this
kind of chunked up pretty like
compressed context window of what kind
of is like the the background of this
agent's memory. And the nice part is
that this scales sublinearly, right?
Like that's the most important piece is
that as as you have more interactions
and more and more time with this agent,
uh your number of tokens to keep the
memory like uh up to date is not a
linear scaling anymore. Um and there's
bunch of chats in here. Um no, this code
is not open source, but I'm happy to to
share snippets of people if if you know
they would like that. Um
Josh,
would you not summarize
Go ahead.
Again.
No, go ahead.
Uh Josh, we we we don't summarize um by
topic. This is specifically for the
agents memory. And I'll go into a bit
more about like the how we store topic
stuff later is like we make heavy heavy
use of stateful tooling which is again
kind of like a reversed like spun around
version of rag. Right.
This was so cool. Right. You're using
the tools themselves to offload some of
the context management and they have
their own kind of stateful memory like
like isolated to the context of each
agent instance that is might be using
those tools. Right.
Yeah. So to me this this was like
obvious. I didn't know this is like not
a thing that people were doing a lot of
yet. But it's like it's very obvious
that like I don't remember all of the
emails in my inbox. That's why I have an
inbox, right? Like there there are tasks
like this that I just am not able to do.
I can't compute those in my head, you
know, and so I know that like my
workflow for this is check my inbox,
look at what's in my inbox and whatever.
And so we we distinctly don't actually
include that data for like inboxes, SMS,
we don't really do specific stuff in
this memory summarizations because we
don't want them there, right? We want
the memory summarizations to only be
about like what's happening during the
tutoring relationship, where's the
student and their progress, all that
stuff, right?
um
out of the model design.
Yeah.
Uh with with long-term versus with
variable just on this chart um is with
variable that's the DRM the decaying
resolution where it just gets more and
more summarizy over time.
Mhm.
Okay. And what is with long-term? Is
there a is that like an in between
diagram that's actually not in here?
Well, with long-term, it's just like if
you make big summaries of what's
happening, but it's still just summaries
every n like every unit of time. Like
maybe you do weekly summaries as your
long-term memory, right? Because then
you can say, "Hold on, we got a
short-term memory, which is here, and
then weekly memory, which is here, but
it still scales linear linearly with
weeks." Um, which is just like better
than just having short-term, but it's
not quite as good.
Um, I see a head up from Steve
insight before sleep goes on. I think
the real insight. Can you scroll up
here, Brian?
The real the real problem here is I
think a this is like when first people
are first introduce like merge sort for
the first time like oh [__] that works
and you keep sorting in a small bit. It
actually works really well and it's
really elegant and it feels really
intuitive the first time you see it and
the first time you write it. Um, but I
think what you're probably running into
here is for the first time like people
are like, "How do I get this thing to
remember everything I've done over the
last two years?" And the answer is you
don't.
That's the thing. The trick is you
don't. And once you reframe that problem
and say, "How do I get to remember the
most important things?"
Now you have a separate task which is
how do I make good monthly summaries
which is a separate LM problem that you
constrain and say are my monthly
summaries good? And you can build an
eval
and that will be use case specific too.
Um, exactly like you can you can choose
what you want to happen and what you
want to be in a summaries. Um, and but
monthly summaries for monthly summaries
for a tutoring bot is going to be very
different than monthly summaries for
chat GPT than is going to be different
for every other use case. And so you can
eval this and you can test it and you
can stub it out and you can build a
product around it and you can look at it
in isolation which makes it easy to kind
of build these different this this is
the engineering part. How about even
how about milestone? How about
milestones summaries?
It's all the same.
What do you mean by that?
Uh I I think the whole concept here is
like you you understand your problem
definition and once you understand your
problem definition, you then have to go
and scope it out accordingly. So in this
case in the tutorbot case, I don't care
about details like the dog's name. I
care about seeing the academic progress.
So what I want to make sure is actual as
I funnel down from actual messages to
daily summaries to weekly summaries to
monthly summaries. I basically am
expecting a loss of information in each
of these steps. It's like a funnel of
information being lost. That's by design
a good thing. That's what I want. But I
want
you want smaller context. You want
tighter, more focused context.
How do I question in zoom?
I haven't used Zoom much. Uh why are we
focusing why are you focusing so much on
time rather than just token size?
Well, that's the context window that
that seems to work well for Brian's use
case, I'm guessing. But that's the
point. You can decide as a developer
what you want to go use for your thing.
So you might say that hey for me token
window size matters but semantically
what I suspect is for many use cases
time is a good orientation because what
I'm doing a month ago is probably very
different than what I'm doing today.
It's very very unlikely for it to be
continuous. But what I'm doing today,
like when I'm doing a cloud code task,
every single cloud code session is its
own session pretty much. Very rarely do
I resume a new session. But whenever I'm
doing that, it doesn't matter how big
that context is. That is all
semantically relevant. And I might still
Claude code does something called
compacting the context window, which is
very relevant. But it's the same thing.
They realize that the context for them
now is getting too big. Let's build a
smaller subset of it that we can
actually pass in and maintain. But then
we go into cloud code rules. If you
scroll up again, Brian, sorry, can you
scroll up? Yeah. Then we go to cloud
code oh into that diagram. Then we go
into cloud code rules. And cloud code
rules kind of behave like these monthly
summaries which are being injected in
every prompt that are almost like static
constants. Um, and I say static
constants because they're not changing
very often, but they're being injected
in and then the model is kind of
understanding that. And this part is the
part that is growing ephemerably as I go
on. Okay.
And this is like what the model
compacted and put on.
Stephen,
hold on. Let's just I we have a ton of
questions piling up. I I want to let
Brian finish his walkthrough of the blog
post and then we'll do all the questions
because otherwise I don't think we're
going to finish.
That's a good point.
Uh, sorry Brian. I'm gonna I'm gonna
mute myself too.
All good. Um I think the really
important here someone asked about
context or about token count is that not
only does this method scale sublinearly,
it actually like tapers off. It's like
not quite asic, but it's like pretty
close. Um and so like even if you're
doing if we're if we're working with a
family for five years, you're still only
at a max of like maybe call it 60
summaries, right?
um maybe maybe a little bit like 65,
right? And so each summary is like a
like maybe a hundred words. That's like
still not that much tokens. And so our
at least our our bet is like the context
windows that are available with these
models will scale faster than our memory
will require, right? Um
um so yes, all of that memory is being
put in the prompt. Um but it's because
it's lossy. It's like it's not all of
the information, right? It's like it's
only the most important stuff from the
past that's being put in. Um,
the other thing I want to harp on
Yeah.
No, go ahead, Brian, please.
The other thing I want to harp on is uh
how like what we store in memory and how
our to use of tools actually changes
this where like like the email inbox
stuff like Orin which is our our tutor's
name has an email inbox and and that
email inbox is isolated based on uh kind
of every like customer unit which is
like a family for us. And so when he's
querying his email inbox, we only show
him the stuff that would be like
isolated to this family, right? And what
that means is that we now don't have to
store all of that information in memory
because whenever he wants to look at his
email inbox, he can just go look at his
email inbox, right? And we do the same
thing for email. We do it for SMS. He
has a calendar that he can use. like all
these very basic like just knowledge
work tools that all of us use um to
offload our own memory onto these like
software systems we also can give to
agents to basically give them the same
abilities. Um
let me let me describe that really
quickly just so I I articulate exactly
what I think you're saying. Typically
when people do like querying a tool
that's like a tool call or like a
structured output kind of concept that
people are doing and usually they'll
have the model output like the user ID
of the person they want a structured
output. You're saying the only tool that
you're giving the model is query search
the inbox search the inbox then has an
implicit ID attached to it
for that user. So the model doesn't have
to think it doesn't have to think about
the idea of user permanent users at all.
there is only one user from the
perspective of the model and is that
what you're saying?
Well, that's not entirely true. Um there
there's only one family from the
perspective of the model, but when you
search the inbox, he also has a contact
book that he can use, but that contact
book like there's an implicit idea of
like every Orin has
family's contact. It's it's that
family's contact.
It might have like the mom and the dad
in the contact book, right? and it will
have to give one of those ids as part of
the tool call. But the the model itself
is like sandboxed into only being able
to operate within the scope of this one
family. Right.
Yeah. I see that mistake a lot in a lot
of prompts when I see them is like
people are asking it to load some
database ID and they're literally having
the model regurgitate the database ID
from the prompt or something that they
injected in. I'm like why even do that
work? just let the model pretend like it
doesn't have to think about that and let
just like pass that along to the tool
manually
rather than having to go do that work on
in the model side because it it's more
complexity on the model side
I do still have that where it's like I
want to go check my email but from this
email address right which is like the
dad's email right or the mom's email but
there's there's the the scope of valid
options is much much smaller than if you
were to give it access to the entire
database right and there's also like
because our customers have direct access
to the to the agent, there's huge
security concerns
where like
I we we cannot like we cannot put in
context information about other
families, right? if for your agent that
you're working with like you just can't
do it. What if it leaks something just
like a zero you have a zero tolerance of
risk for that because there's also a lot
of kid information in there
and that's
yeah so there's like we have to like
there's fura stuff like there's there's
just structurally we cannot have any any
leaking risk here and with this there is
no leaking risk right
yeah because the tool itself is
inherently tied only to that ID that you
have hardcoded in to your system
pretty much yeah
do you want to see before we answer the
questions is I'd love to see one of your
prompts
Can you share that with us?
Yes, I can share prompts. I can share
codes.
I'm not going to share evals, but I can
share everything else.
I Yeah, I actually I understand that
sentiment. A lot of companies that I've
talked to share that same sentiment. The
secret sauce is the evals
and the prompts and everything else is
is like, "Yeah, sure. You can take the
prompt. We'll have a better prompt like
two months from now. It's fine." Uh,
I can even share like how we made the
evals, but I'm not going to share the
evals.
Yeah.
Um,
let's take a look at some of the
prompts. I'd love to see them.
Yeah. So, I I I do think it's worthwhile
also briefly going over the productivity
piece just people understand like why
these things are running without human
input,
right? Um, like basically we let the LLM
set their own wake schedules and so Orin
can wake up at midnight while you're
sleeping and do something if he want if
he wants to, which might be creepy, but
like it's possible, right? And so what
happens is that like when he wakes up,
it's not just in response to something
that something that the user has done.
He can wake up and then like text you a
reminder, right? Um, and I can show uh I
just I just ran this locally and I can I
can show kind of another one in a minute
how how it works. But this is like one
one trace of running the actual what we
call entity which is like a deployed
version of orin for one family.
Um,
and so what we do is like before
anything runs we make sure that all the
summaries are updated again. In this
case it was all it was all done. And
then this is like one of the prompts
that would be piped into these models.
And so we basically like okay, first
thing we tell here's your memory
context. Uh and we include the the the
date and time. Um and then this actually
is a bit out of order, but we give it
all of the tools with descriptions of
what it can do more so than just the the
schema in um like in in the structured
uh outputs kind of tool schema.
And this is again why structured outputs
is part of context engineering, right?
is and I've seen a lot of people do this
where you put the scheme in at the end
but then you also put the descriptions
in the system message.
It's more it's also just because like we
we care about um being very like we want
him to be very human in when and how he
uses these tools, right? Because if if
we frame the tool as like here's your
email inbox, he has many examples in
sample of the model training of when and
how to like use a email inbox, right?
Um, and so like the framing of the tool
matters a lot. Um, so yeah, we have a
lot of different tools that you can use
here. Um, but then like we have a we
basically have a big prompt that's just
like here is um here is like your job
manual. This is very high level like
what you want to be doing as a tutor
like you know what you're supposed to
like what what does healthy look like in
engagement? What's a healthy customer
look like? All that stuff. a bunch of
like not really if then instructions but
just general stuff. Um, and I guess this
one actually didn't have any memory
because I ran it fresh. Um, but what
happens here is it goes through and let
me condense this input out. So it goes
through and um now starts to call some
tools and we basically do a while loop
where it's like it calls tools until it
calls the sleep tool, you know. Um, so
like it's going in here and it's saying
um tool is this.
It needs to
Yeah. So it needs to like check the
email threads. So it's checking its
inbox right now. And then we we come
back and at the end of all this we
return back the JSON of of the email
API, right? U we don't really do a lot
of like augmentation in this part of the
rag. We just kind of get it back like
JSON responses and that works pretty
well. Um, and so it's like, cool, I've
called the email tool. I got my response
back. Cool. I can see there's emails
here. Let me open the test email, right?
To see if there's a student. Um, it
calls that tool. We append the content
of that email to the prompt. And then it
says, great. Okay, let's open the second
thread, whatever. This uh for this for
this version of Orurin that we're
looking at right now, there's like
pretty much nothing in the stateful
tools except for like one or two test
emails, which is why it's like, you
know, kind of just like scrambling to
figure out what to do.
Um, so it keeps opening up email threads
and then it's checking its calendar,
right? Looking for upcoming lessons
within the next 48 hours. Um, of which
there there are none, right? And so, um,
all emails are old, no actual messages,
whatever. And then it basically decides
to, uh, go to sleep. And it has just
like a tool it can call. It's just go to
sleep. And it's going to set a time of
like where when it wants to sleep until.
And the important part is like none of
this happened in response to a user
input. We do have certain wake events
that come in and and all that stuff, but
like none of it happened in response to
user input. And then we take all of
those messages at of what happened
during this conversation. And uh we do
what we call enshrine them, which is
just like summarize them and store them
in the longer term memory. And so after
this one run ran um it goes through this
tutoring step, right? which is like it
takes in or sorry this summarizing step
which is like it takes in all of the
messages from this uh this history
including all of the data including all
that stuff. Um
and then we basically ask it to uh
summarize what that would look like and
somewhere in here oh here we go wait
somewhere in here there is a prompt
about how to summarize stuff but if it's
not in here I can just show you it in
the code. Um
yeah, let's see.
Code is code is always a lot easier.
Yeah. So like we we have a lot of
examples about uh how to summarize
different types of uh different types of
summaries like like direct interactions,
daily summaries, whatever. Um, so for
for summarizing this direct interaction
of like what happened just now as you
did this, we care about like I don't
know what what mediums did you interact
with, who did you talk to, like what did
you do? Um, that kind of stuff.
And I also find
way a lot of I should pause a lot of
people over here don't do the stupid
thing. Do the DED thing. Don't
do the DED thing.
That's good. Anyway, I'll
do the dead thing.
And then we give examples of just like
what a good summary for a certain
interaction like could look like, right?
Just, hey, fot prompt this, you know,
here's here's what it might look like.
Um,
and then we've also like
I want to note one more thing about your
fot prompt really fast. Can you go up?
The one thing I noticed about the fot
prompt is you're not actually telling it
the input. You're only describing
outputs, which is good because you're
basically helping understand the
structure of what kinds what is a good
summary without actually telling it
here's how you summarize this piece of
content exactly.
You're giving it like clues about
examples, not really prescribing that
this is a summary for this example.
That's a great few shot example. I I you
people on the call know that I harp on
fuchsia all the time. I think it's ass.
It's because people do it wrong. This is
a great way to do fa.
Love it. Love it. And we do this for all
the different like uh like types of of
how long how long we want to chunk up.
But also this has been surprisingly
helpful just adding this to every like
like almost waterfall of memory where
it's like
when you're summarizing the day what
should be remembered for the rest of the
week, month and year like include all
that stuff too. And like we use 03 to do
all of our summaries as well.
It's pretty good at that. like it it can
kind of just like figure it out and be
like, "Oh, that's an important thing
that I should include in today's summary
because it should be remembered for a
lot longer than just today, right?" And
that ends up waterfalling up into like
becoming like basically getting put into
um like some of these buckets and not
just this bucket.
And the idea here is in the daily
summary, if you highlight that this is a
good weekly summary note, then when the
weekly summary prompt runs, it's like,
"Oh,
yeah, it has that
part of the daily summary. this is a
good weekly summary. I should probably
take care of this. And if I see too
many, I'll pick the best ones out of all
of them.
And that's kind of the idea.
And and and you'll see in the future
stuff like our examples get more and
more broad kind of like how we would
want the summaries to get where it's
like, you know, you're not really saying
much about like specifically at four
o'clock we did this thing. It's just
like, okay, this is the daily summary.
So today we did a session here like the
parent reached out in this way and kind
of we set up set up a plan, right? And
then weekly it gets all the daily
summaries of that week. Um and so it's
like even more broad, right? Like more
focus on student progress, more focus on
like the pedagogy of all this, right?
And then monthly you get you get very
broad.
Yes,
your examples are listed in different
formats for different parts of the
prompts. There's a part where you do
example one, example two, and then
another part of it where you do
um
ah true
just calling it out. Please go
there's only one for the longer ones
there's only one example rather than
multiple examples
it looks like right
these are examples
I just
but then
I just changed it from from this
yeah uh but none of these are run
synchronously so it only ever will see
one or the other and like you said it's
a staple reducer so it's like
you know
I'm sure I could ease out to figure out
which one's better but honestly just
haven't
and then like we have a more broad like
prompt for everything which is like cool
here's a who you are making memory
summary whatever
um we also like we want uh we we allow
for like long like longer summaries when
it gets to more like weekly and monthly
stuff um and we also we we plug in the
existing condensed like like summarized
memory we call this whole thing just
like the memory context like all of the
buckets right we plug in the existing
memory memory context in the memory
summarization prompts which has actually
been really important, right? Like it we
found that if you didn't give the
summarization prompt all of the memory
from before of what's happened in the
entire history of this like this or
being deployed, uh it it would miss
things that were previously identified
as important,
right? We
we saw similar things when we were
building the AI content pipeline where
we had like there are parts of it where
giving it the full transcript was useful
but at some point we stopped giving it
the full transcript and gave it
summaries that we wanted to give away
and it's the same idea but some steps we
did need both the summary and the
transcript and other steps we only
needed to just
like for example here maybe you have a
kid who has a history of like some kind
of executive function problem and that's
well documented within in the existing
memory that's happened before. But then
if you're summarizing what happened
today, that might not have come out to
play today, which is actually a notable
thing that you should summarize, right?
Like you should include the fact that
there were no executive function
problems today in today's summary
because that's notable bas based on the
past summaries. And so if you if you
don't have all the past context, then it
you know, even your summarization it
kind of goes goes is off. Um,
and then yeah, there's not a lot else to
the summarization part here. Um,
basically we just like fill up the
string.
I just want to say by the way, thank you
for sticking with the vibe of today.
Like I know Dexter and I usually try and
actively write code, but uh today I know
we had seen Brian's article and we
thought it was much more useful to see
his code rather than like have us write
code like we normally do. So I just want
to say firstly big thanks to Brian for
actually being bold enough to share the
code live. Not a lot of people are
willing to do that, especially for a
startup that he's building out there.
This is a recording so people have
access to these for a while. And I'm
sure Bri is going to make his props
better because like you said, emails are
the things he can't share.
Um um
and eval with this type of agent are
like especially hard.
I feel pretty confident in our
deliverable is that
um we should talk about that. Um but
with that, I I know we're 10 minutes
over, we're 11 minutes over. I want to
take the rest of the time to really help
answer questions that people might have
uh in the chat. I know people wrote a
lot of questions in the middle and we
kind of glossed over some of them.
Um but if people want to go back and ask
some questions again or raise your hand
really fast. Uh we'll let you come off
and then we'll we'd love to have you on
to do a quick little
uh Q&A session for next 15 or 20 minutes
as long as Brian's willing to stay on
with us.
I'm good.
Cool. I don't see how I can raise a my
hand here.
It's at the bottom in Zoom. There's a
thing called raise hand. There you go.
Uh but Radu, you since you spoke up,
come on up.
I'm sorry. Yeah. So, question to
uh Dexter. So, Dexter, your diagram, I
showed um context, engineering context,
and uh I I was keen to see if there is
an intent.
uh part of that um because as you can
imagine especially in SLMs
you don't want um uh any kind of
question prompts to do to be sent to the
SLM but uh the if it's MCP tools it
knows it can do XYZ
and also um it could uh say that the
tool description
uh matches or does not match the user
question intent. So capturing
inferring that um how how important that
is.
You're talking about kind of like
capturing the user's intent to in terms
of like protection and guard rails.
uh not just authorization
um but also um
think about that um the user
uh the entire user base asked um all the
questions are 75%
are uh for this kind of intent category
and the rest is that so you you get a
feel of what the the end user community
is is how is it using the SLM?
And of course, yes, uh that once this
intent uh um u I would say list or
taxonomy is
um
more so fleshed out than it could be as
a base become as a base for
authorization as well.
Yeah. Yeah, I think that's probably
slightly off topic for the context
engineering thing. I understand the
value of it. Maybe maybe it's another
episode we could tackle.
What do you think?
I agree.
Yeah, go ahead,
John.
Yeah. So, I I think I think I know the
obvious answer to this, but I just want
to validate my thinking. Um, if there's
a memory from three months ago that it
realizes from that memory dump is
important
or irrelevant is probably a better
answer. it's relevant, but it needs more
detail about that memory that is not uh
that is not there.
Do you just do a tool call to whatever
system is obvious from the memory to go
get that information? Like is is the
memory dump you're giving an indicator
of where to get more details and then it
does a tool call to get those details
and then it processes that. Is it that
simple?
Do you want me to write the code real
time? Let's do it.
Not not function. I think I'm thinking
of it more in terms of a line of
thinking. We're doing this in a business
context and like that's how we're
architecting it is the way a human
would, right? I'm not going to remember
every single term of some enterprise
deal we did six months ago, but I'm
going to remember the name. I'm going to
remember what this guy's talking about
today is relevant to that deal and then
I'm going to go look up our how we dealt
with that one, right? Like is that the
Brian?
Brian, do you have like agentic
retrieval tools for like drilling down
into memory stuff, I guess, is the
question to summarize it. I I I don't
think that the paradigm of
giving the agent tools to access its own
memory is a very good paradigm because
it pro to me it just smells that there
are like you should just add tools that
are act as surrogate memory that makes
semantic sense about what you're trying
to do. So for example it's like maybe
you're in a business meeting and it
needs to remember details about the
business meeting. Cool. You shouldn't
give it a tool to let it go access its
own memory. You should build grain for
your agent,
right? Like you you should build a a
meeting recorder for your agent that
sits in the meetings and then summarizes
that in a notepad for it that it can go
query later. So like it's kind of the
same thing when you think about it, but
the framing for the agent actually makes
a lot of difference where it's like the
agents don't have a good intuition, at
least in my experience, of what exactly
memories I should go get and like how
those interfaces should work and like
there's a lot of insample data about
that. But if you have a tool that's like
here's your notepad, all of your meeting
recordings get auto summarized in this
notepad. It knows what to do. Like cool,
let me go find the meeting that I had
with this guy six months ago. only go
like query you know the recording for
that meeting and get the transcript or
get the summary points
what's the difference in that case of
making clear that fathom or granola is a
tool it can use or pipe drive is the
sales CRM or those types of things like
what is there a functional difference of
why you wouldn't do it like that
just accessing these third party tools
yeah I mean if for us it doesn't doesn't
quite work because we have to like build
our own internal tools for it but yeah
if you can just use Fathom like do that
man like just have Fathom join all your
your agents calls and then web hook that
in to like store the data somewhere and
then just tell it like hey we use Fathom
like go get your Fathom stuff and like
it will have insample data about what
Fathom is and how to use it. Like
we have our own little uh like version
of like a Zoom client that we use.
It just wants to use Zoom like it
continuously tells users that it's just
going to send it a Zoom link and like no
it's not a Zoom link you know but like
it's it's biased toward wanting to use
the in sample tool. So if you can do
that like just give them the example
tools man.
Got it. I think that's the part I need
to dig into.
How how how will it choose the right
one? I I'll dig into that particular
part.
John, to highlight that point a little
bit, we talked about this a little bit
in our 12 factor agents episode. And I
think this is the part that a lot of
people think about which is like how do
you define these concepts? But I think
what you really want to say is there's a
decision point that the LLM or some
function is going to make that says
instead of emitting the final result
that I want. I wanted to request more
information.
So in this case, I have a really simple
thing like extract a resume. I'm going
to use a really really basic example so
we can all go over it. It's going to go
do this thing and like we have boundary
ML over here and what I'll say is
company startup
or enterprise. I'll just say that
there's a company type over here and I
want to return what company type it has.
Um, and I've just wrote the prompt if
information about if information is
missing, request more information before
continuing,
right? And when I go run this prompt,
you'll see what I'm actually doing. I'm
literally just telling the model like
either dump out the resume
or request more information. That's it.
And I might even put into here like
action resume uh extract
complete. And I'm naming this very
differently than the previous one. I'm
naming it extract complete resume
intuitively.
And this thing is not complete. It
doesn't have a start date. It doesn't
have an end date. It doesn't have
anything. And I'll make requests um a
bunch of this. And I'll even put like a
reason kind of thing in here. Why not?
Reason string.
And I'll say here's all the requests I
have. And I should probably name this
request.
And when I go run this in theory, I
don't know if this will do the right
thing.
It did the right thing.
it was able to go through and decide
that it doesn't have it doesn't have
experience for the company name the full
name associated with initial VBV is
different from vivov gupta just go
double check everything so now you can
imagine what I would do in my python
code is I can then opt into what I want
to go into here so I can do something
like
and I think it it ends up being the same
concept to what you're talking about
from client import bh
sorry import
So when I get like a res is it going to
be extract resume and I actually pass in
like the string into here whatever the
string ends up being this thing is going
to be either request more information
type or resume type. So now I have a
choice of what to do
if it's a client.types types
import request more information if now I
can basically go ahead and handle these
requests in some way and that can be an
agentic loop it can be something else it
can be and now what I have is like
initial resume
uh state is going to be like a
resume stir
why I pass in a resume stir into this
and this can just be like a state how do
I do
I mean,
you're basically building a tool calling
loop. I think this is kind of what John
proposed is like, do I give it tools or
structured outputs that it can give and
like yes, your code can decide whatever
you want to do with those outputs,
whether it's just direct query from Zoom
and stuff it back in the context window
or you want to send a Slack message to
somebody who can help or whatever it is.
Is like the model's only going to just
say, "Hey, I need more information about
this stuff." You can decide how you
handle that.
And and the thing that decides whether
you need more information or not is just
the function. The fact that this
function happens to use a model is an
implementation detail of how I did this.
You could write a different function
that is not an LM. For example, you
could write a simple function that's if
the word bank statement is in there like
a simple reax match, then I will always
request information about the Chase bank
account associated with this account.
I will just require that. In fact, I'll
tell the user if you haven't connected
the plaid can't do this action. I won't
even go to an LLM.
But that's the whole point of thinking
about everything as a function
signature.
Does that answer the question really
well?
Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. I think
we're on the right track with the
pattern. Um, I appreciate it. Thank you.
Uh, Derek,
thanks. Took me a second to come off
mute. Um, just a quick comment that's
worked well for us is um, owl time. Uh,
specifically the Allen algebra with
temporal um, like time intervals. So if
you have multiple agents working as a
team uh you know with the turns in the
conversation it can help to keep track
of what happens in what sequence.
Um so I know you've got a different
notion of the roll up with time. Um I'd
just be curious if you've thought about
any of the temporal or if you've got
agents working together. Um I appreciate
what you said. I think it was not we use
mentoring but you used uh the term
tutoring. Uh so we've got like you know
a whole thing with that. Uh but the
larger the teams get that are working
collaboratively
uh we found it to be pretty complex.
We've maxed out at about kind of 25 on
one team to be able to manage that. So
I'd be curious of any aspects about uh
the temporal relationships you have.
Thank you for Thank you for today. This
has been really great.
Could you repeat the question again?
Sorry. Uh
so you said owl time which is I believe
the like ontology knowledge graphy like
expressions of time right?
Yeah specifically and in fact using that
with BAML and Neo4j as as well but uh of
ontology of temporal relationships with
time there are 13 time intervals that
are defined uh uh you know during
etc. Uh yeah, so this has been we've
integrated this over the last like six
months uh to to for so everything kind
of happens those ones at the bottom the
relationships and their inverses is a
clear way to look at it. Um so when you
have multiple agents running together
kind of in stasis and then coming back
where they're active. uh with
multi-threading. This is how we keep
those async operations amongst a
collaborative team
uh all working together with different
roles uh and instantiations of those
threads because we don't just like
instantiate one and run it. We run like
the full context window uh typically um
and have a whole onboarding process
for for an agent. So I just was curious
if you've incorporated anything. I
became aware a few months ago of of what
you were doing with these different
grouped rollups. It was a nice nice
thing or just take a different approach.
Um but I' I'd be curious. Thank thanks
again for your time.
I haven't personally tried that
approach. Uh it looks really
interesting. I think um in general all
these attempts that I see are always
around like this idea of like somehow
there's this loose structure of like
what is a prompt and it's these really
sequence of tokens and all these
attempts are just attempts to like put
into some structured format that is a
little bit less loose than just like raw
strings and that looks like another
really interesting format like I would
be really keen to hear more about your
feedback as you've been doing this and
like what learnings you had maybe in
another episode Derek and it' be really
especially
if you're willing to share some of the
code. I think that the idea of
connecting it from knowledge graphs to
entities and relationships over time is
a problem that a lot of people are going
to have long term.
Oh god. Um, one thing I just want to tap
into that was brought up a couple times
and um, that Brian mentioned is this
idea. It's actually in 12 factor agents
is factor 13 is um, I think Brian
mentioned something about like why why
let me know if I'm paraphrasing this
right um, but like the idea of like why
wait for the agent to call a tool to get
information it needs when like if you
know the agent will always need that
information or will always be useful
just inject just fetch it yourself and
inject it into the context like
deterministically.
Yes.
Is that right?
Yeah. This is why I'm like not always
the biggest fan of of like letting the
agent control what like memory is in
context because
all of the stuff that are in our like
canonical memory should be in context
all the time. It's important, right? If
it shouldn't be in context all the time,
it should probably be in a separate
siloed state full tool is our that's
kind of our philosophy around it where
it's like it's like why do you think
that should be only in there sometimes
and like what about that information
can't be stored in like a separate tool
that makes like semantic sense.
Nice. 100%.
All right, we'll do one more question.
Josh,
hey, thanks. Hey, thanks um Brian. Um
it's usually helpful. So, two questions.
one um in the um in your blog you
started with the hey we saw problem. So
uh first question is that the after you
implemented the this memory what did you
see what behavior change did you see or
benefit did you see and second question
is that the um at the bottom now next
steps you kind of highlight that the uh
better like um more persistent temporal
memory why did you select that as a next
step as versus like slicing by different
topics or whatever so I'm kind of
curious about those two
we kind of do with with topical things
um Again, topical information should be
in context some of the time. It's kind
of our viewpoint. It's like it's useful
for some things and not for others. And
so, like we we've basically we're
building an internal LMS right now for
our agent to use which stores topical
information about like the students
progress and kind of the frontier of
their knowledge, all that stuff, right?
I mean,
if you had like a a kind of like a tutor
who was like maybe had a memory issue,
like a human tutor that just couldn't
remember stuff very well, like you'd
want to give them all these tools to
enable them to to be able to still tutor
somebody effectively, right? And so we
want the temporal side of like
relationship management, which is
honestly mostly for for like
interactions with the family and not
actually for the the tutoring quality
itself. And then we're gonna we're
building like tools around storing
certain information about what the
person knows. Um that like maybe you
could use a graph to represent that in
like a different a different context. Um
but like the point is like silo out kind
of what your memory should be. We care
about the temporal part because we want
it to be like a relationship that you
have for months and years, but then also
we care about things like uh like
topical information, but we just store
that somewhere else, right?
Hopefully that answers the question.
Got it. And the first question is what
benefit did you see after you implement
this?
Well, we didn't really anything before
this like this was our we started
building this from scratch basically. Um
but the biggest benefit is like for us
parents actually feel like this thing is
responsible and will like like it feels
less like a tool and more like a service
because it has this temporal memory. It
can be proactive.
um like it'll hit you up and be like,
"Hey, do you want to do this stuff for
your kid this month or like you know,
you mentioned going on vacation, I'll
I'll give you this week off, you know,
stuff like that." Things that would have
had to been built into like very
specific workflows without temporal
memory are now just they just happen,
right?
I think I think one of the similar ideas
is uh like when when we first do like
use like something like Google search or
like any sort of new technology for the
first time there's these wow factors
that we look for that make it really
amazing and Brian's technique that he
applied here gave his parents the first
wow factor in AI which is proactivity
I think when everyone knows that you can
go try and have it go do something the
magic is when somebody texts you and
says does the right thing happen it's
like kind of like the email when we The
fact that the email doesn't feel super
automated. It feels somewhat human
written.
That's what makes AI feel good. And this
temporal memory strategy
did that for Brian in his use case for
the constraints that he defined for the
evals that he wrote. And it looks like
they did a lot of work to make it work
for their problem, but that required a
deep understanding of their problem and
their users to go give them that wow
factor. For everyone else that's going
into this, it's not to say that DRM is
going to solve your problems.
The point here is understand your
problem. Understand that one wow moment
that you really truly need for your
business situation to work and figure
out what data structures you need to
solve that problem. These are all just
fundamentally data structures and
algorithms problems. We're going to have
leak code. Leak code is not going away.
Leak code is just about to get a whole
lot [__] harder. That's all that's
gonna happen. Um,
yeah. I think
I think this like DRM productivity thing
is probably going to hurt your business
if you're not selling a service
honestly. Like like if you're trying to
sell a tool, I would stay away from
that, right? Like the people who are
using tools want like the kind of cursor
feel where it's like it's not quite like
I don't like think about like an
individual that I'm working with, you
know? like I'm I'm able to to mess with
stuff and like just just do it at my
speed, right? But if you're trying to
sell this like full stack service,
temporal memory is like super important
for just continuity, right? Of like
like just like the normal like PM [__]
Like
if I have an EA for example, like that
EA if it's an AI agent,
it better not need to be reminded what
the [__] BAMO is every single week. Like
that just doesn't work. and it should
know the vision of what your company is
doing every single week and like be able
to like understand semantically what the
notion is going on on top of my head and
what's top of mind today and the best EA
are the ones that proactively go do
things so whoever builds that service is
going to have to go build something like
this whether it's CRM or some other data
structure that ends up being even better
or not but this is a pretty good start
um
the other warning I will give about
proactive stuff just just real quick on
the last
is uh if you want to be proactive and
you're giving the keys of like
scheduling to the agent itself, you now
have to work with time zones again. And
that is a whole mode in itself because
the models are not good at time zones
and you have to do a lot of
normalization and augmentation of your
context windows to make it look nice and
have and basically cater to the model
about what like how they should output
stuff.
And would that I can write a whole
article about that. with that.
Don't try to solve time zones in a
prompt, right?
Yeah.
Sorry. What did you say?
I said with that, we're back to context
engineering. It's all context
engineering. Put the right tokens in,
you get really good tokens out, but
understand the problem. Put great tokens
in.
We're two minutes over. Um
we
This was awesome, y'all.
We normally do.
This is super fun.
Uh yeah, thank you guys. Uh we'll send
the recording like we normally do on
Fridays. Expect to go see it. If you
want to continue the conversation, join
the Discord. Uh send us an email if you
have any questions. Uh see you guys next
week. Next week is going to be a lot
more coding. I hope that we can do some
of this context engineering tips and
actually start writing some code next
week. So we'll maybe we can do a part
two where we actually do the coding from
this week and actually real live code it
from scratch. Thank you guys. It was a
pleasure. Thank you Dexter. Thank you
Brian for making time uh and everyone
else that steps steps aside. See you
guys next week.
Luck. Catch y'all later.